[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream r16 we have heard you
internet loud and clear and we promise
you more cat Belle is coming not only
more frequency of the Rings but higher
amplitude so stay tuned for that I am
sitting with dr. Heather huiying we have
many things planned for today we are
going to have a discussion that will
last for whatever period of time it
lasts and then we will switch we will
take a break and then we will switch to
another link which will be findable in
the description to this video at which
we will take your super chat questions
so you can file those questions during
our discussion here and then we will
take as many of those as possible and
then switch to super track questions
filed in the Q&A all right I thought we
would start today by talking about the
catastrophic meaning-making crisis that
we are facing and what we might do to
bootstrap our way out of it let's do it
all right so the place I want to start
is this as many of our longtime
listeners and followers will know I am
an evolutionary theorist
now people do not generally have a good
grasp though on what theorists actually
do and I must say there's something
about the term theorist that when I hear
somebody described himself as a theorist
I roll my eyes just like everybody else
but nonetheless theorist is how I
understand my my scientific role and
what it means is that there are some
tools in the theorist toolkit which I
believe are not well understood by most
people that I think are actually vital
to the crisis that we find ourselves in
now let me just say that although this
isn't where I thought we might be going
that when I hear theorist and you are
indeed an evolutionary theorist I don't
I'm not really like I can play along but
it's not really what I do
more of an empiricist and I think of
those two things as counterpoint to one
another and both as necessary and I
don't know if you see these two
approaches as sort of compatible with
one another but very much describing
different parts of the process is that
yes would you say so 100% each necessary
to the other in fact you will remember
many years ago as I was engaging the
questions surrounding telomere
senescence and cancer in a fit of
frustration I wrote a mad poem and this
very point was made in the center of
that poem about that these two things
are they are hands that he loads best
together was I think the phrase but in
any case and I wish we had that poem
right now we could read that poem that
would be perfect it would be so we're
trying didn't think - yeah I think we
just need to define the terms and let me
just let me start with empiricist it's
easier it's more straightforward it's it
is a in closer alignment to what people
imagine if they have an accurate view of
what scientists tend to do and most
people don't think of theorists as even
in the realm of possibility all right
there's a lot we've talked a little bit
in past live streams about the
difference between a hypothesis driven
science which is also known as
hypothetical deductive ism versus
data-driven science I tend to use the
square quotes versus you know conclusion
driven conjecture which is being passed
off as data-driven science a lot these
days both of these the theorists and
empiricists both ought to be if they are
actually doing science driven by
hypothesis in trying to you know driven
to either generate or generate
hypothesis most fundamentally as what
they're doing as opposed to most
fundamentally be testing hypotheses and
so an empiricist often may be sonata
mised mostly aptly with experimentalist
is someone who makes an observation
generates as many possible hypotheses
that there might be to explain that
observation generates prediction
which would inherently follow from each
of those hypotheses and then begins to
try to test those hypotheses
specifically my hope hopefully in the
pop Aryan universe trying to falsify
those hypotheses and so it is that act
of testing via either carefully
controlled observation or experiment
that is the empirical part of that
process
it doesn't think that that description I
just gave doesn't include the analysis
which is generally data analysis which
generally statistical analysis and it
doesn't put as much of a focus on how
how was it that you generate your
hypotheses in the first place and are
you outside of the scope of what other
people have even considered and so you
know I found for instance that I had
particular skill I never knew before I
started spending time in the field alone
at yes making observations and
generating hypotheses and predictions
but specifically in figuring out what
experiments would accurately test for
distinctions between hypotheses and so
that's what the empiricism is that what
experimental design and then follow-up
data analysis would allow you to
distinguish between hypotheses that's
sort of more the realm of empiricists
where as theorists spend more time
earlier in the process and often are
doing not sort of brick in the wall type
science but parent you know would seek
to do paradigm shifting science well
there are two things in here one is what
exactly does a theorist do and then the
other is what is their objective okay
and so let's just say I think that
there's actually a confusion in the
public's imagination about theory that
arises from the expectation that a
theorist generates theories which is not
true a theorist cannot generate theories
so let us step back into a dialogue that
we've all heard many many times that
will begin to unearth the question so
we've all heard at some point some
person advocating for the teaching of
some creation theory alongside Darwinism
in school or something and inevitably in
making the argument that there
be done they will make the claim that
Darwinism is just a theory right and so
why shouldn't other competing theories
be taught right alongside it now this is
actually a non sequitur right it's it
always reminds me of I don't think that
the word amines what do you think it
means right the the word theory has a
very precise meaning and if it is
understood precisely then the claim that
Darwinism is just a theory of course
doesn't make any sense and this is
always what you hear the scientific
establishment responding to these claims
that these creationist theories should
be taught alongside Darwinism is that
the word theory is as close to a fact as
scientists ever get but then when we
travel around in other disciplines we
find that this isn't true the term
theory is invoked all the time for
things that are not as close to effect
as we ever get in science and in fact
sometimes it's used for things that
aren't even remotely fact like and we
don't when we it would be easy pickings
to go after grievin Studies Fields here
right and you know and even legitimate
humanities and social science fields
which tend to use theory you know
literary theory and such really broadly
and too liberally and frankly and
accurately but we don't have to go there
we can we can stick to talking about
science and the misuse of the term
within science right so theory is
actually the top of a hierarchy of
concepts and the reason that we're
raising this and the connection to the
meaning crisis is that if one
understands how elegantly these
different kinds of ideas fit together
and lead to each other then one
discovers that the tools for fixing the
meaning-making apparatus already exist
they are well understood at a
philosophical level but they are not
widely understood even people who study
science for a living are often quite
vague on these things so for example we
frequently see in the major journals
papers that have no relationship they
report data of some kind but have no
relationship to any hypothesis that is
described anywhere and what you and I
have generated over years of teaching is
the idea that every paper that report
data ought to be doing one of two things
and it ought to say which it is it is
either data leading to a hypothesis or
data that tests a hypothesis data should
never be collected in isolation of those
two things either you're looking to
unearth a pattern that needs an
explanation which would be a hypothesis
or you're testing an explanation that
has been provided either by you or
someone else in order to see whether or
not it stands up to to that attempt to
falsify it and this is in fact one way
to make the distinction between data
driven and hypothesis driven science the
data that were collected and I don't
even love to use the term data here but
will do it data that were collected
absent a hypothesis in which the
researchers were letting the data reveal
patterns that the humans behind it
didn't actually have any idea about what
might be true have not tested anything
they what they have done is the first
step in the usual scientific process
which is in fact a cycle that such that
they have now generated a hypothesis but
the results of those papers that use
data to produce a hypothesis even though
that's not what they say they're doing
compared to papers that actually test
the hypothesis by having hypothesis
generating data and then figuring out if
the hypothesis is borne out or falsified
the results of those two types of papers
are often are often boy you just can't
even tell the difference by the way that
people talk about them or respond to
what it is that they're claiming and in
fact they're very they're very different
in terms of the standards of proof that
they are then letting loose on the world
yeah in fact there's a kind of rarely
spoken but widely detectable sense that
hypothesis testing is almost an archaic
mode that we've gotten past it because
things have gotten more complex or our
technology has allowed us to see into a
level of detail where that doesn't work
and of course it's nonsense I'm reminded
of the faculty member I taught with once
at Evergreen who revealed in front of
the class and this is a direct quote I
used to think hypothesis was important
now I know better
so again I want to stop on a step back
there's a lot of things that need to be
sort of in the mix here in order to
ultimately get to the power tools and
really from the point of view of those
of you listening or watching at home the
real point here is if you understand how
these tools work and it isn't all that
complex your thinking will without
knowing anything new become that much
more powerful these things enhance the
power of what you already know to an
immense degree so hang in there if this
is a seeming far afield where was I
headed I was headed somewhere you were
going to explain what a theorist is well
oh yeah that's one thing I think so a
theorist
I know what it is there's a question I
have said elsewhere and actually it's
gotten quite a lot of positive reaction
that every great idea
starts with a minority of one right if
you're going to change the way a field
sees something then it's first going to
occur to you and you'll be the only
person who believes it until you come up
with something that might demonstrate to
others the need for them to pay
attention to it which frankly sometimes
takes decades right so it starts out as
minority of one but in a world where
what you have is endless appeals to
Authority what that person says makes
sense because of the credential they
have I'm going to believe it that world
in which ideas compete based on how
appealing they are or who's saying them
is not a world in which the idea that
occurs as a minority of one can ever win
because it will always be driven to
extinction
by the majority who may have a vested
interest in preventing the idea that
offends them from ever gaining currency
so how is it that these minority of one
ideas ever take hold and the answer is
they take hold because of an elegant
scientific philosophical system that
says exactly what is necessary in order
for your idea to replace the ones that
preceded it and it doesn't anywhere
mention anything about authority or
credential or publication or any of
those things it has nothing to do with
them what it has to do with is whether
your idea explains more and or assumes
less
than the ideas that it is replacing if
you come up with an explanation for a
observable pattern and your explanation
assumes less than the preceding
explanations or explains more of what is
observed then it is taken to be correct
so it rephrase that slightly which is
the only scientific method explicitly
rejects any kind of gatekeeping there is
no stay in your lane admonition within
the scientific method and we have come
in modern science to do a lot of
gatekeeping and a lot of a lot of
finger-wagging and stay in your lane and
oh you don't have expertise in that
therefore you can't speak to that or you
can't apply for grants in that and some
of that is maybe some of that some of
that is maybe necessary in a giant world
with a lot of people vying for very
limited resources a little bit of how do
we channel interest in funds and such
but the vast majority of it if not
nearly all of it is now being used as a
way to keep out ideas that are in fact
heterodox that are more shamanistic that
are more about consciousness as opposed
to established culture that might break
the wall that is the current paradigm
and whatever scientific interpretation
we're currently working under as opposed
to put it yet another brick in it and
another brick in the wall science is
absolutely necessary and it's terrific
assuming the foundation on which you've
built it and the wall itself is an
accurate representation of reality so
I'm gonna take a little detour and steel
man the gatekeeping okay I hate to do it
but I think it's the right thing so
there is an argument that we need a kind
of gatekeeping at the boundary where we
take that which we think we know to be
true and we try to enact it as some kind
of policy obviously we have to have
somebody empowered to say that idea is
not worth taking seriously if we're
figuring out how to allocate resources
or what medicines are safe we have to
have some kind of gatekeeping
the problem is once you establish that
and it seems like gatekeeping is what
keeps the world functional then it gets
transported into the philosophy of
science where it doesn't belong it just
kind of gets grafted onto it and it gets
used by people who have perverse
incentives to shut down their
competition which is both
philosophically wrong and very bad for
the world it results in us being farther
behind in what we understand then we
would otherwise be so I was just about
to add on and say this is exactly what
we see in peer review which seems like a
good a good proposal but became so mired
in its own internal perverse incentives
that it is really hard to trust but I
was reminded before I began saying that
that you were trying to steal man the
idea of gatekeeping and I'm not sure I
totally heard the steal man know that we
need it when we get to what are we gonna
do okay what is correct we don't need it
and I would say when I hear it there's a
point at which you take what we think we
understand and you know it's imperfect
but you have to translate it into policy
there's some kind of gatekeeping
necessary there and you know I do not
like gatekeepers and I think they've
become so corrupt that I just I'm not
defending anybody who holds the position
of gatekeeper but I am saying in
principle what I want is some standard
by which we figure out how to translate
what we think we understand into policy
that eliminates some of the hazard that
would otherwise accompany that step and
it's the idea there that the abyss
between the people who have figured it
out as if who figured out what is true
and the people who think they know what
to do about that truth is typically so
deep such a big chasm that there are a
few people who can actually interpret in
both worlds like what why is that the
moment that gatekeeping you think is
maybe most easily defended as necessary
as opposed to the various other moments
well I mean you know to take a trivial
example there is some hazard that
from the update process and us theorists
must pay no attention to it all right it
is a non-factor right the objective of
the exercise is to figure out what's
right and how you're gonna establish it
but that is not the same thing as trying
to you know make a Planet function and
prevent harm to people and things like
that so you have to have some mechanism
that isn't you know your policy isn't
gonna change on a dime the day you
realize that something you thought was
this way is actually that way you have
to have some coherent practical policy
now again I hear myself defending
something I absolutely detest the end
use of this process and you know you are
an extraordinary example of someone who
does do both of these things and you
know perhaps that's the reason for some
of the criticism that comes down the
pike at you in particular which is that
no you do this thing but it's it's it's
all very much of the tunur of stay in
your lane we know what you do you know
get out of get out of our space and yeah
its territorial it's it's pissing on
boundaries all of this so what how do
you maintain that gatekeeping which is
necessary while still allowing those who
can who have the chops to and who are
willing to transgress boundaries that
most people can't transgress all right
two things the answer to your question
comes down to a principle that we've
advocated to students for you know a
decade and a half mm-hmm which is it is
natural for your science to affect your
ideology write what you know to be true
will certainly affect what you think
ought to happen it is completely
unacceptable for your ideology to affect
your science that is to say your
ideology doesn't change what is true at
all nor can it be allowed to so it's a
one-way relationship so asterisk you had
a second thing yeah I have something to
say in response to that okay the second
thing I wanted to say is when I hear the
word peer review now I have the sense
that I'm hearing somebody say something
analogous to the Patriot Act right
duck is a desperately unpatriotic
document but it's labeled in such a way
that you'll think it's doing this job
peer-review seems like well you don't
want the peers to evaluate your work
can't be very good no I want my peers to
evaluate my work I want them to do it to
do it in public and I want them to show
their work so that if they turn out to
be wrong then the credit flows the right
direction if they turn out to be right
I'm also interested in the credit flow
in the right direction but it has to
happen out in the open because otherwise
what happens is people abuse this
process to shut down their competitors
that's right so that was the the second
piece that we shouldn't be misled it's
just like data-driven data-driven sounds
like a it sounds like a defensive
empiricism and who could possibly be
against empiricism but that's not what
it is it's data-driven yeah data is
driven is hidden behind the word data so
people will think that all you're doing
is saying something obvious that every
scientifically minded person would
embrace when in fact it's a coup against
hypothetic code adduct of science by
just this endless cycle of observation
yeah and it's you know you could without
changing the meaning at all and it
wouldn't clue too many people off to
what was coming on but you could instead
of saying driven say first data first
versus hypothesis first do you want your
science to engage hypotheses first or
data first and if it's data first you've
got a problem because you have to go
through many more iterative processes
before you've actually tested a
hypothesis and since most the science
doesn't do that you actually don't have
a full cycle of the scientific method
with regard to your first point you had
said it is unambiguously clear that
humans being humans as they do science
will find as they learn things through
their science that their worldview is
affected by what they have learned but
what we cannot have is that that process
going the other direction which is to
say we cannot have ideologies affecting
science and this this reminded me of you
know the objection yes this gets deeply
modernly political very quickly but you
know the
the admonitions from many of many people
emerging from grievance studies but also
many some good faith academics and
thinkers who are making cries for
greater diversity in science for
instance and you know the easy one to go
to because we've both thought about a
lot and talked about it a lot is we need
more women in stem all right we need
more women participating in science
technology engineering and math and you
know this is this is not the place to go
into all of the ways that the that the
statistics that are usually trotted out
here are often misleading and the goals
that people are advocating for are
probably not the goals that we should be
shooting for but I remember saying to a
number of earnest smart but frankly
confused young mostly women but some men
at a conference that we were
participating in actually in the summer
of 2017 after Evergreen had blown up
before we knew that we weren't going to
be faculty there anymore when when they
were asking me when we had opportunity
to get up and talk about what is the
nature of sex and gender the evolution
of sex and gender actually and what does
it mean about proclivities and abilities
and desires and all of this I said what
who you are what your particular
demographic is should have absolutely no
effect at all on the results that you
get if you are doing good science it
should have no effect at all and
therefore in that regard with regard to
if scientists are just being handed
questions to address then the particular
answers the answers that are coming out
of those scientific questions should not
vary based on where those people are
from what sex they are what color they
are how old they are with this issue
economic background is any of that and
that's of course a perfect world and
it's not exactly totally true but the
fact is a scientific process
specifically is you know is about
extracting the bias of the human doing
the work such that you can get to a
result that would be true no matter who
you are but what isn't the same is what
questions you choose to ask so the place
where diversity diversity to use you
know it's super nuanced and politicized
term now but the place where we the
reason that we actually do want
a more diverse pool of people doing
science and asking questions across all
domains is that your particular history
which includes your worldview which
includes whatever political views you
have because of the questions you've
asked in the past will affect the
questions you ask and the questions you
ask are of course part of the purview of
what you do as a scientist so diversity
doesn't matter at all for the results
but it doesn't matter for the questions
which of course affects the results it
it shouldn't matter for the results but
for the kinds of corruptions mental and
otherwise that enter into the process so
we are gonna have to get back to the
basic structure here no no we're
somewhere so important though and I will
say I do think there are certain
questions and this goes back to
considerations of empathy and who you
will have an easier time understanding
yeah there are places where I do think
our field has actually wildly [ __ ] up
not to put too fine a point on it
because for historical reasons that have
nothing to do with this field in
particular it was historically done by
men and so what it discovered the order
of things that discovered had a lot to
do with what males are more likely to
see and what they're more likely to be
unable to see and so my favorite example
of this is Jane Goodall who the great
hero of mine I know of yours as well
saw her video this week actually was
great to see she's usually travels all
the time but under lockdown she had time
to make a video I think that defending
bats wonderful thank you Jane but anyway
I think Jane Goodall cracked the code of
the great apes where men had failed
George Schaller's in particular had
failed with the great apes after he had
succeeded with lions actually but she
cracked the code because a she was not
over educated so she didn't impose what
she had learned from her elders on her
chimps but B she had the intuition
to avoid the male bias against
empathizing with her study organisms
there was this sense that it would be a
play a scientific corruption to you know
to have to be more Phi's your creatures
but of course we're talking about sorts
of grief for naming them right and for
claiming that they were doing things
like engaging in war or no friendship
well and you know the key thing that she
did was ingratiate ourselves to her
study organism so that they would ignore
her enough that she could understand
what they were up to which you know came
an absolutely necessary part of the
study of social behavior of anything
that is in any way conscious you know
you don't I didn't I didn't particularly
need to ingratiate myself with my frogs
they they would fall on me from trees no
matter what and ignore me mostly but if
you're studying you know dolphins or
elephants or chimps or any primates
really or crows or you know a number a
number of organisms and you would need
to and was it was it Leakey I can't
remember now which big name in
anthropology tapped not just Goodall was
leaking so it was Louis Leakey you know
just just to add a little bit more meat
to this story yeah Louis Leakey who is
this you know big old man in
anthropology says what we really need in
order to understand human origins and
human behavior is a is a better grasp of
what is going on with the at that point
we thought three extant species of great
apes bonobos were classified as a small
species of chimp so he didn't have
people going after the bonobos but he
said I'm gonna find three people who I
can send to the field for a long time
and see if they can't crack you know
crack the code so to speak of what it is
these that chimps gorillas and an
orangutans are doing and he was quite
explicit about choosing three women he
chose Jane cuddle Goodall for the chimps
Dian Fossey for the gorillas and beretta
galdikas for the orangutans galdikas
says I believe still working in the
field and Fauci obviously was killed by
poachers and and and Goodall has become
and massively important cultural figure
and and probably has helped save not
just many chimps but many other
organisms throughout her work and his
Leakey's position was not just okay but
the men have been trying and they're not
getting anywhere but I leak II actually
think that there is there was a chance
that women actually have more empathy
and are going to be better able to put
themselves to basically do the theory of
mind trick and imagine what it is like
to be a chimp a gorilla
an orangutan and therefore get somewhere
it would be studies and of course all
three of those women were trailblazing
and we really we know much more than we
would have had their bet had they been
any other individuals including most
women right but that there is some kind
of work that the particular propensity
is and proclivities on average of men
versus women may make one or the other
more suited to that work yeah so and you
know it's interesting that the story is
that you know the grand old man of
paleontology sent these women to do this
work because he understood that they
would get it better and I think history
bore out his suspicions so anyway it's
it's a complex story I would say there's
one other place that I think our field
has screwed up as a result of a kind of
male cognitive bias that's blinded us
and it has to do with our
misunderstanding of male sexual displays
and lekking species and that there is a
way in which men who don't entirely get
women have looked at the fact that
females in many species require males to
do these elaborate seemingly senseless
things and they're you know they had
kind of a you know female suit against a
reaction and anyway I think had the
field incorporated women more quickly we
might have fixed this one sooner so one
more anecdote here before you get back
on let me say I do think we have the
answer to that puzzle and at some point
here it's going to emerge and I think
it's a fully satisfying very
the answer but what would relax about
anyway yeah what why why does the
peacock have such a fancy tail we know
why he has it
females require it but why do the
females require it that's the tough part
yeah so the anecdote is you know animal
behavior and especially the study of
social behavior was of course biased
towards mostly males doing it for a very
long time just because of the the
history of science and how and how work
of any sort really outside of the home
has been done in humans and there's a
book by Sarah bluffer hurdy who is I
don't know she are academic so sibling
yeah so she was a student she was an
early student of Dick Alexander's right
so right boomers she was oh yeah she was
she was a when she was an undergrad when
he was a graduate student okay so Sarah
black for her tea is an extraordinary
researchers who worked on worked in
India on langars and has written a
number of excellent books including
mother nature which has different
subtitles depending on when and where it
was published but it is such an
excellent investigation of the basis of
social behavior in mostly primates
including humans that it was and I you
know we've talked before about neither
of us really ever liked to use text
books so this was one of the key books
that I would use in my animal behavior
programs and it is mostly an
investigation of social behavior through
a female lens it's about mothers and
daughters and how fathers come into the
picture and in pair bonded species how
important they are in a non pair bonded
species how the females have to defend
against you know putative fathers and
would-be would-be intruders and all of
this and at the end of I think it was
the first time I taught a nobody if
you're using this as one of my books
that we seminar Don every week
I remember hearing some it was good
hearted way it wasn't it wasn't deep
criticism but some sort of grumbling on
a field trip from some of my male
students that they hadn't had any idea
that the field of animal behavior and
the study of sexual selection was such a
female biased field I thought oh my god
I had no idea that that could be an
interpretation but I feel like
inadvertently I just I just flipped the
expectations
they're ahead because no one I don't
think in the history of the study of
animal behavior had ever before voiced
the concern but it was two female bias
and it's really just you know which
which stories and written by home do you
run into first and yes if you're
studying social behavior you really do
need both men and women doing it if
you're studying quirks it's not clear to
me that you do and if you're studying
you know medical procedures it's not
clear to me that you do although medical
procedures need to be done on both men
and women because men and women have
fundamentally different anatomies and
physiologies and everything else
um and it's also worth pointing out that
our era the era in which we studied in
graduate school the our mentors were all
of a generation that they could be
forgiven for a certain view of women you
know a throwback view but none of the
people who mentored us had that view
they were all very farsighted like her
dad was and had excellent female
students that they produced because they
had no such bias so anyway
kudos to Arno Kluge and dick Alexander
and Bob Traverse all of these men were
ahead of their time with respect to
understanding how broken that particular
chauvinism was just just not caring they
didn't they didn't have alleged female
students didn't seek out female students
I didn't give you out the job right you
got you know can you can you talk
science can you know can you generate
hypotheses and experiments and all of
these things and if you can't I really
don't have the time for you and I'm not
gonna be gentle on you because you're
female and I'm afraid you might cry or
something you don't know if that's
that's chauvinism to and none of them
engaged in that either not in the
slightest all right so let us some
return to the meat of the map yeah
theorists do not create theories they
cannot what theorists do is they advance
hypotheses and those hypotheses if they
survive test and ultimately go on to be
the default assumption of the field that
is the moment at which they become
theories so I think the important thing
the reason that this is so deeply
connected to the meaning-making crisis
and the possum
route out of it is that that process
whereby you take a minority perspective
you demonstrate its importance and it
replaces the dominant paradigm this is a
rigorous mechanism whereby heterodoxy
becomes the new orthodoxy and orthodoxy
has this bad connotation but in this
case what I simply mean is it is the
standing of what we commonly believed to
be true you know that the earth goes
around the Sun is now orthodoxy as it
should be it's almost certainly correct
how did it get there well it started as
a minority perspective that had to win
the day through this process so to make
the process a little clearer just
realize that mathematics has an analogue
of this whole thing and the terms are
different but the logic is very similar
it's not identical but it's very similar
so in mathematics you can offer a
conjecture that's a proposal that's the
equivalent of a hypothesis you can offer
a proof of the conjecture a proof is
analogous to a hypothesis test and if a
conjecture is proven then it becomes an
axiom and what an axiom is is the
default assumption for what is true it
has become axiomatic so in science
instead of doing those things again it's
not exactly the same but it's close you
observe a pattern you hypothesize an
explanation for the pattern the
hypothesis is effectively a conjecture
that comes along with predictions and
then those predictions allow you to test
the hypothesis and see whether in fact
it stands up to that rigorous challenge
at the point that something has stood up
to enough challenge that the default
assumption of the field is that it is
true then it is a theory and so this
explains the mysterious conversation
that we hear so many times where people
allege that Darwinism is just a theory
and that that means that other theories
should be taught alongside if that is in
fact a non sequitur because there aren't
other theories there is only one theory
of how life became
complex on earth and it is Darwinian in
one form or another so let me just
reiterate what you just said in a
slightly different order because I think
it's important and it bears repeating a
few times scientists a hypothesis as
Malthus - conjecture
so I father says conjecture are the same
thing in science I'm out space science
is to test as math is to proof right
testing in science is like the proofs in
in math and science is to theory as math
is to axiom and I think you've also said
more postulate or theorem in math right
so science has hypothesis and testing
theory and math has conjecture proof and
axiom also postulates and theorems and
that those are you know more or less
analogous points with one important
caveat distinction between theory and
science and axiom in math which so to
get to I'm I'm a little out of my depth
here I'm really not a mathematician
although obviously there's math in my
family very close by but the difference
I think is that when a conjecture has
been has a proof has been delivered that
has withstood scrutiny I believe it is
accurate to say that the axiom that
arises is simply true and we don't have
to worry about it being falsified
because the nature of proof is such that
proof isn't like a big stack of evidence
that something is right it's an ironclad
demonstration that it is right and so
once something has reached the status of
axiom is it beyond disproof I suspect it
is so that's different than in science
where a theory Darwinism could be false
let's say for example we are living in a
simulation and Darwinism was hard-coded
into it or the appearance of Darwinism
was hard-coded into it in order to
figure out you know what we humans would
think in response to it then it's not
real and the appearance that it is real
is explainable by a larger hypothesis
which could be potentially demonstrated
but nonetheless it could be false and we
could discover it but at the moment we
have no reason to
think that's coming any more than we
have reason to think that we're gonna
discover that the earth doesn't orbit
around the Sun one of the distinctions
at least in the realm of science that we
often engage in is also the test is as
you said basically based on a stack of
evidence that then endures basically a
probabilistic assessment statistics is a
probabilistic assessment and because
it's probabilistic the theory that may
result after many many many tests in the
end the test of time as it were is still
based on probabilistic analysis whereas
a proof is not generally probabilistic
it is it is yes or no Egypt this is
either accurate or a proof from you the
steps have been binary and so there it's
it is not a probabilistic situation yeah
right so one of the outgrowth of this
that I think people who use the term
theory casually don't understand is that
there should really only be one theory
for a given observation at a time the
theory is that which is so likely to be
right that it is taken as the assumption
and it can be displaced by some other
theory but then it's no longer a theory
it gets demoted to the status of
hypothesis and in fact it's a falsified
hypothesis at that point so that is an
important fact theory is not some
infinitely large space it is not
something you yourself produce it is the
result of a combination of things
actually it's a result of the exact
combination of the team work that you
were describing before right you
generate a hypothesis the empiricist
tests it sometimes the empiricist is
also the theorist but it doesn't matter
but the end product of the cycle is
theory so why are we so confused about
this this is the this is the problem and
this is uh this is a difficult one to
deal with because what we have just
described is the way it is supposed to
function it very frequently doesn't
function inside even inside of fields
where we wield the term theory as a
defense of for example Darwinism where
we swear that the creationists don't
know what they're talking about because
they say Darwinism is only a theory and
we say you don't get what that
term means right even inside of a field
where we need that defense
we're not consistent about the use of
the term but there are other fields in
which a much worse job is done and I
think that this is the problem part of
the crisis and meaning-making
has to do with the fact that there's not
even a standard between disciplines
about how to use these terms so I would
say the worst offenders in my opinion
outside of maybe the the humanities who
abuse the term a theory like nobody's
business and maybe we'll return to that
but the worst offenders inside science I
would say are the physicists who very
frequently when they talk talk as if
they are advancing theories which
doesn't make any sense if you use the
proper definition and this resulted in
immense amount of confusion that frankly
I think is hiding in broads in plain
sight right I think anybody can see it
so there's a hierarchy you have
something that isn't a hypothesis it's
an idea it could be true but you don't
know how to test it it doesn't make any
obvious predictions okay that's a notion
or interpretation okay it's not
necessarily wrong but it's below a
hypothesis a hypothesis is an idea of
why something might be the way it is
that comes with a prediction that would
tell you if it was false right so it has
a higher status because it comes along
with something that gives it the
potential for being eliminated if it
isn't true a conjecture doesn't have to
be you know we can conjecture that this
is one of a you know a billion universes
and that would have no implication for
us here in the universe so you know I
can't say it's true or false but it's
not as good as a hypothesis and then
you've got you know a hypothesis that is
withstood test and if it withstands
enough tests that it becomes the default
assumption it becomes a theory right so
that's the hierarchy you've got you've
got notions you've got hypotheses
you've got theories which are hypotheses
that have become the default basically
they have in a legal sense you
say they have the presumption of being
accurate and they are capable of being
removed but until they are we just treat
them effectively as axiomatic but what
do we do with something like string
theory why do we even call it string
theory if I'm to understand string
theory has yet to deliver a testable
prediction now that doesn't mean it's
wrong but it does mean it's a notion or
an interpretation it's not even a
hypothesis and if we discussed string
theory as string notion or you know then
a little bit of its cachet as it should
and you know again that doesn't make it
wrong but it doesn't deserve the status
of theory the top level right the
default assumption now what happened in
physics if I'm to understand again I'm
not a physicist but I'm what I
understand is that effectively string
theory socially won the day people were
so excited by the idea that it
effectively killed off all of its
competitors and it took over the field
despite the fact that it had yet to rise
to even the first level of scientific
rigor which we would be to deliver a
prediction that could in principle allow
it to be tested so until we realize that
that there are things out there
masquerading as theories that aren't
anything more than a notion we have a
real problem and I think that this is
actually corrupting field after field so
in our field pan psychism pan psychism
the idea that consciousness is written
into the very particles of the universe
that's a nifty notion but that's about
all it is doesn't make any prediction
that I'm aware of about nature it's
there it is actually a response to the
difficulty of the study of consciousness
and that's it it's some idea that would
just simply render it outside of our
purview and therefore not our problem
and so I don't take it seriously at all
I don't see any reason anyone should but
nonetheless it is talked about in
serious
circles as if it were something
scientific when in fact it hasn't it
hasn't even risen to the bottom rung of
the ladder so you've got a category
notions into which you've currently put
string theory and pants autism and I
think I think it's a great bin to start
filling with things that have been given
probably more press and more importance
than they would seem if for if only for
the fact that no one pointed out not
testable therefore couldn't possibly be
a theory because not testable means not
knowable and can't even be a hypothesis
yeah and I should say I'm violating one
of my own rules here I know I'm kind of
being a dick by condom notions that's
really just designed to annoy people
okay maybe a new name for the bin well
the bin has a name um its interpretation
right so is it yeah I mean it is in
physics so at the Copenhagen
interpretation Oh example so this again
points to another one of these things
that's artificially been boosted because
it's a cool idea but it still hasn't
reached the bottom rung which is the
many-worlds interpretation right the
many-worlds interpretation is consistent
with you know events happening the way
they seemed to or seem to this is
emerging 100 ish years ago maybe this is
yes in response to you know but that
will slit experiment and the Schrodinger
experiment or thought experiment but
anyway the point is yes you can solve
the puzzle by imagining an infinite
number of universes springing off of
each other I think it's the worst idea
I've ever heard but but nonetheless I
get that technically it's consistent
with what we see but that doesn't that
isn't even the first level of saying
okay it's consistent with what we see
but you want to make it a hypothesis
tell us what it predicts that we don't
yet know to be true yeah right I would
say likewise the in the interpretation
that this is a deterministic universe or
could potentially
be a deterministic universe if the point
is in a deterministic universe you
wouldn't know because all of this was
predestined from the very first particle
interactions yep then you know okay I
get it but what does it predict so the
bottom line here we have a rigorous set
of tools it involves using terms that
people have butchered by misusing them
and if we can resurrect those tools and
just use them consistently and well I
believe we are halfway out of the
meaning-making crisis because we will at
least know what the hierarchy of ideas
is you know are you offering a
hypothesis is it a theory is it just a
notion you know knowing where things fit
I believe will be very helpful and I
probably should not point out that one
place where this is very important is
hypotheses of collusion which get
dismissed by boosting them to the level
of theory which they don't deserve not
until they've been demonstrated so you
know Watergate to call them collusion
hypotheses now do we well I'm using the
word collusion because conspiracy has
become so tightly associated with the
word theory that it's like an instant
grounds for dismissal and so my point
would be Watergate is a conspiracy
theory right we all assume it happened
right lizard people is a falsified
hypothesis we can falsify it on the
basis of phylogenetics right 9/11 was an
inside job that's a hypothesis right
it's not the theory right I haven't been
falsified as far as I'm concerned but it
fits in with a bunch of other theories
including the the 9/11 Commission's
theory of what happened or hypothesis
and what happens hard to keep the
harvick even straight yeah so anyway I
don't know let's try to be consistent
with the terminology I'll try to do a
better job that I just did there in that
last sentence but Watergate now that's
the conspiracy theory yeah good yeah
all right we're we're not too far from
an hour do we want to just touch on a
couple of addendums and corrections from
previous shows
and then take a break okay I think we've
got three of them here let's see in the
super chat last time someone asked about
a paper that's on a preprint a psycho a
psycho that's like free prints surfer
but asks does this pandemic make people
more conservative regarding gender roles
and a quote from it is in terms of
threat people can embrace traditional
ideologies to cultivate meaning and
purpose environmental uncertainty that
is can promote desires to preserve the
status quo this effect is observed
historically in u.s. presidential
elections throughout which times a
greater societal threat to the
established order hybridity increases in
preferences for political conservatism
reference specific evidence for Yoast
and colleagues 2003 motivated social
cognition model of conservatism also
comes from findings that people in the
u.s. reported more conservative
attitudes after the terrorist attacks of
9/11 than before regardless of whether
they personally self-identified as
liberal versus conservative similarly
increased salience of the Ebola epidemic
in 2014
predicted preferences for more
conservative political candidates so all
of those are referenced in this paper
and the authors go in with the
hypothesis that well actually a few
hypotheses that people will actually
shift to the right to politically during
a pandemic which they find no evidence
for incidentally and then two other
hypotheses if memory serves if I can
find it here boy there's a lot of sort
of jargon a gobbledygook in here
epistemic existential motivational
processes you know does a pandemic
render people more strongly conforming
to traditional gender roles and
believing more strongly in traditional
gender stereotypes both of which they
claim to find evidence for which is
interesting if true and raises a number
of questions that we might just talk for
a couple of minutes about start us off
yeah I'm having trouble remaining
objective about this claim because
you know I'm I'm watching the pandemic
as as a scientist and in general I'm
pretty good at keeping things straight
and on the other hand and I'm watching
it as a father and I'm having the sense
of everything that makes life work is
coming apart without clearly without
anybody having an understanding of what
replaces it and you know we're not going
to be locked down forever no matter what
happens even if we just end up facing
the virus and you know tens of thousands
die needlessly which is not something
I'm advocating and I know you're not
advocating but even if that's what we
end up doing we will escape lockdown
soon enough and things will go sort of
back to some kind of normalcy I don't
think they go back to normal if they go
back to something but I do think we've
lost our innocence and I wonder I really
wonder about how how romantic love
emerges from this for people who are in
the early phase of their life where
they're still trying to figure out who
they are and who they're going to be
with and how they're going to find them
and how they're going to court and woo
and do all sorts of things that they're
gonna need to do whatever the modern
terms for those things are so anyway I
guess I guess the point is there's you
know if I hear that people return to
traditional gender roles in part that
goes very much against what you and I
have been advocating which is that it's
time for a renegotiation of those roles
because so much is different about males
and females in the world we live in on
the other hand you know at least there's
some pattern there there's something
that people could depend on and and this
is I mean I think I think the argument
which is that in times of deep
uncertainty where maybe what you need is
a totally new approach but knowing that
totally new approaches are very likely
to be flawed the shaman is
more likely to be wrong than right even
though you need the exactly right
shamanistic approach people are more
likely to retreat to the known
comfortable they understood even if its
patterns that they themselves were
fighting against before yeah so yeah I
mean that does feel a little bit right
that we do need until the new way has
been plausibly spelled out and you know
the way this is done in the context of
modern markets is nothing like a viable
new way but until some new way has been
spelled out until somebody has proposed
the renegotiated arrangement between man
and woman I get why people would retreat
mm-hmm so let me just say one more thing
about this paper which I read it just
quickly before this and you haven't had
a chance to yet so you don't you have
not looked at their methods with regard
to testing whether or not people were
endorsing gender stereotypes at higher
rates after the pandemic or during the
pandemic versus before for which they
found statistical evidence their methods
I find really weak and a little strange
and that's not I think just because I
find the gender stereotypes themselves
no not not particularly comforting at
all but a man like I put you on the spot
and say what you'll come up with some
gender stereotypes here but I think all
of us just listening and so such can
imagine what it is that you might think
you know what is what would it be like
to be more masculine or manly you know
think of some things and now would it be
like to be more feminine or womanly
think of a few things for a moment and
now let me share with you the words that
they used which is that you know they
treat these as they say endorsement of
traditional gender stereotypes was
assessed by eight items of these eight
items for items assess attitudes towards
men and four towards women so we got
eight words for Everage is supposed to
be more masculine and for every supposed
to be for feminine for the masculine
ones we have risk-taking brave
courageous and adventurous that doesn't
strike me as four things it's like I
love them all but that doesn't strike me
as
independent things and four attitudes
towards women the four things that they
supposedly did were clean hygienic
sanitary and pristine which problem with
the category but it's only one category
right like they have basically braved
versus clean and like I could I could
tear apart they like women are clean
thing but you know probably most people
watching or listening came up with some
version of courageous or risk-taking her
adventurous as being a typically more
masculine trait but and you know that
which many women would like to you know
are also engaged in a lot but this isn't
eight this isn't a things at most it's
two and one of those two which is
represented by four words here is
questionable in and of itself so I'm not
compelled by at least that part of not
this research I ain't seen the methods
but that sounds like a weird kind of
pseudo replication exactly yeah exactly
okay so there's a lot more we could do
on that paper but let's since I think
we're coming to an hour let's just
quickly talk about two more things that
have come up in the past oh I don't know
which live stream it was we were talking
about that Contra Costa study that that
presumed to show that invited people via
Facebook and it turns out the wife of
the principal investigator was
specifically promising people that they
would be able to get tested if they came
up positive they might be more likely to
go back to work in Contra Costa County
which is the county in California that
has San Jose Silicon Valley etc we
talked a lot about the various reasons
that we didn't trust the results well
there's a there's another thing now that
I own lis find it on BuzzFeed news which
is obviously a questionable source but
they find that they whistleblower
complaint has been lodged at Stanford
claiming that JetBlue's founder helped
fund the study and that that which is
potentially a pretty big conflict of
interest in the financing the study was
not disclosed in the publishing of the
study so you know one more thing to make
a suspect that that whole that whole
study was politically motivated at bat
and but don't you know potentially quite
skewed I don't know if you have anything
well kids if you're going to go with
corrupt study design go big or go home
it's the lesson here there you go
okay and finally I think it was last
time or the time before you were talking
about the aircraft carrier that okay
fill us in here yeah there was an
alarming report this is one of the
things I fear most in this crisis an
alarming report of people who had
recovered from kovat 19 who were showing
signs of a new infection and this would
be disastrous it's still possible off of
the IQ just can't think of the name of
yours a belt yeah um so this would be a
terrible thing if you if it turned out
that having had it once didn't mean that
you were immune not even for a short
period of time that you could get it
again almost immediately so what we have
now begun to see I'm gonna put the
screen Zack South Korea is evidence that
the second wave of positive tests on
these people is not the result of new
infection but it is in fact the result
of them shedding forgive the term here
for a second but dead virus people will
complain about that and they'll say
viruses are not alive to begin with we
don't need to fight about it the point
is you've got viruses that are capable
of inducing an infection these are
complete viruses and then you've got
fragments and these tests are such that
they don't detect an entire viral they
they detect a particle that is
recognizably viral in origin but that
does not mean that you have active virus
in your system so I think in this case
they were actually shedding dead cells
from their lungs that had been infected
and it's not surprising that those would
have molecules that would trigger these
tests yeah I don't know if it was lungs
because the only one last thing I wanted
to say about this that you had you would
found this on the Bloomberg site and
strangely they uh yeah I guess you can
put that up Zack you had found that on
the Bloomberg site and they didn't link
to what should have been a preprint
we don't expect it to be a peer-reviewed
article at this point but a preprint and
so I went looking and I found Stars and
Stripes I found other Jones I found
Forbes here and all of them are telling
the same story but none of them have
links to the preprint and you look the
only thing that I see to indicate why is
the top of this Forbes story which says
South Korea's health agency announced
Monday which sounds like it was a press
conference which is really even such a
lower bar than anything else that we
have yet seen this means that really
really hope this is true like this this
flips the script again back to okay
hopefully if you've had it and you've
got antibodies you will now have some
level immunity and you cannot get it
again or have it reemerge but this it's
200 I think they were looking at 400
people maybe 285 of which had it a test
of negative a test is positive again and
they go and find these dead in quotes
virus viruses that are causing the
antibody test to test positive again but
all of that all of that that I just said
is hearsay because it's from a press
conference we aren't we haven't been
allowed into the scientific paper and of
course scientific papers almost never
have links to the actual databases and
you know most people can't do the
appropriate analysis on someone else's
data set especially if they're outside
of their own field but you can do what
we did for instance fun you know this
Rosenfeld and tomiyama paper on whether
or not open pandemic can make people
more socially conservative for what we
did specifically with that Contra Costa
study paper went to looked at the
methods wet methods are not going to be
reliable here therefore we at the very
least can't say that they they think
that they found what they think they
found or they found what they say they
found in this case we can't do that and
that means you know I really hope it's
true but where is the preprint if if
they did this work like it needs to be
out there on the farm of a paper and the
preprints allow multiple revisions up
until you up until it's accepted
somewhere and published so it should be
out there and I really I can't see what
the excuses for it not being available
for people to look at so this is a
particular thing it's
rare in my experience but it's not
unheard of and it is a terrible
corruption of the method this is the
opposite of doing your peer-review out
in the open this is yeah nobody is even
able to access it now here presumably
this is not intentional but I recall in
my own past in my paper on telomere
senescence and cancer I had a prediction
about cloned mammals and in particular
Dolly that she would die of Dolly the
first cloned mammal sheep and she would
die of pathologies that were beyond what
her age would predict she would have and
at the point that she died we of
pathology is beyond the age at which she
was we don't know because they didn't
publish it they told us that it wasn't
the case they told us that they had put
her to sleep to put her out of her
misery because they couldn't stand to
see her suffer from the pathologies that
she had that they start but but she died
far earlier that most sheep of her
species well they for the specifics but
we don't know because they euthanized
her but she did know how old she was
yes they euthanized her claimed it had
nothing to do with age-related
pathologies she did have early arthritis
but in any case it made it impossible to
evaluate so there was a hypothesis test
that had been run effectively but we
weren't allowed to see the the result of
it so anyway this is something it's
something that happens and it is a it is
really problematic when it does all
right I think we're good we are going to
do we want to say something about what
we're gonna do next time or we wanted to
leave that on say I think we can say
something okay um so I I we don't we
don't really know yet but we noticed
that Saturday when we were scheduled to
do our next live stream is May 23rd
which makes it the third anniversary of
Brett having 50 or so students whom he
had never met before show up at his
classroom and chant for his immediately
immediate firing a resignation and
the rest is history and largely
televised as well we have not talked
much publicly just the two of us
Benjamin Boyce did a very nice interview
with us that summer I think and we've
both talked you've talked a lot you know
with with Joe Rogan and they Ruben and
Sam Harris and such publicly but then we
talked to Mike naina
oh yeah Mike Mehra it's done an
extraordinary job but we we're thinking
of spending the next live stream talking
a bit about evergreen and maybe going
over some things that haven't been
public so far maybe yeah
so we'll talk about what it looks like
three years out yeah okay so we will be
back in 15 minutes we will do Q&A with
your super track questions if you are
not subscribed to the channel why don't
you subscribe hit like hit the notify
Bell and set it to all so you don't miss
future live streams and other content
and we will see you very shortly
you